we've had the PC we've had the web we've
had mobile as a platform and we believe
virtual reality is gonna be the next big
platform for entertainment experiences
everyone is going to be having VR
experiences as a very natural thing in
their daily life in this small dark room
at the Silicon Valley Offices of John V
our visitors are invited to try on a
headset and experience the company's big
innovation cinematic virtual reality
cinematic VR is essentially a branch of
virtual reality that's not focused on
video games but it's really focused on
video per se when you watch a Jon
cinematic VR experience you really feel
like you've been transported somewhere
else you can look in any direction to
the right or the left behind you you
also hear sounds in the spatially
correct location so for example if you
hear a phone ringing to your right and
you look over to your right you'll see a
phone ringing and now the sound will
come straight ahead
to create immersive video experiences
John had to come up with a new kind of
video camera the camera consists
basically of a sphere of lenses each
lens pointing in a different direction
and capturing a different part of the
space the really different from
traditional cameras in that it's a very
autonomous system you don't really have
a cameraman anymore
if you have a cameraman he or she would
be in the shot itself this isn't a
totally new concept john's 360-degree
camera is basically the motion picture
version of the Google Maps Street View
camera that one creates immersive still
images
what makes Drott unique is what they
want to do with the technology they want
to put you inside a hollywood-style
movie
in order to make that happen John has
established a partnership with New Deal
studios a major Hollywood special
effects house New Deal's creative
director ian hunter is making a sort of
virtual reality Godzilla complete with a
miniature city and a man in a monster
suit shooting in VR it's completely
different than shooting a normal film
where you have just one camera looking
one direction in this case the camera
sees everything so we built a complete
set 360 degrees around we have to leave
the set during the takes so I usually
wear a ski mask will tiny little eye
holes and that way I can hide in the
shadows and still be able to direct the
VR experience is a whole new different
way of experiencing narrative that
hasn't been explored yet there's every
kind of genre out there we can apply
this kind of technology to and tell it
in a completely different way this is
Erin a Bloomberg colleague I'm gonna
freak out I just want you to she's
watching another cinematic VR movie I
think you're bleeding this one's in the
horror genre
well that was terrifying jaunt is
betting that we're going to get hooked
on that kind of experience an experience
that's about to become accessible to
pretty much everyone there are a lot of
exciting things that are going to be
happening soon in the VR space one of
the most interesting is mobile VR that
is being able to experience the VR on
your smartphone
it really makes VR accessible to a large
number of people and as this reaches a
broader and broader audience
there are obviously great opportunities
to build out a business delivering
content to consumers
jeonse technology is less than two years
old and it still has a ways to go but
it's going to require more than just
technological advances it's also going
to need a new kind of virtual reality
storyteller a Spielberg or Cameron of
immersive cinema you can turn this into
the next blockbuster entertainment
Blackstone